jamie dimon yesterday had some choice
thoughts about bitcoin we've got a
couple of quotes during his talk or his
interview at the institute of
international finance
jamie dimon does not like bitcoin he's
made that very clear over the years he
said yesterday quote i personally think
that bitcoin is worthless okay
he then said quote i'll challenge i'll
just challenge the group to one other
thing how do you know it ends at 21
million you all read the algorithms you
guys all believe that i don't know i've
always been a skeptic of stuff like that
and then he also said quote i've always
believed it'd be made illegal someplace
like china made it illegal so i think
it's a little bit of fool's gold and
that was from a previous conversation
that he had so jamie dimon over the last
couple of days has said that bitcoin is
worthless he says that he doesn't
believe that there will only ever be 21
million bitcoin because he doesn't
believe the algorithms and then he also
said that he thinks bitcoin is fool's
gold
very interesting choice of words coming
from the ceo of a 500 billion dollar
financial institution
but people on the internet all had their
own thoughts to share first we have
brian armstrong the coinbase ceo who
said yes i did read the algorithms
and then i wrote it too i coded up our
own bitcoin node to make sure i
understood it so we have one person
jamie dimon who obviously doesn't code
doesn't understand anything technically
who says that he doesn't believe the
algorithms doesn't believe there will
only be 21 million bitcoin and brian
armstrong who actually understands a lot
of this and has built a 50 billion
dollar business in the span of a couple
of years who said that not only did he
read the algorithms but he rewrote them
to make sure that he understood them
then we have one of probably the best
tweets i've seen in a long time edward
snowden
okay boomer
after jamie dimon says that he thinks
bitcoin is worthless
on top of that we have ryan sulcus who
came out of the woodwork and said jamie
dimon on bitcoin 2014 terrible store
value 2015 it will not survive it will
be stopped 2016. it's going nowhere
2017. it's a fraud 2018. don't really
give a [ __ ] 2019. he launched his own
coin 2020 not my cup of tea 2021 i have
no interest in it it's fool's gold it's
worthless
well that's all pretty interesting stuff
jamie but you've been wrong
on top of that we have mike novogratz
who explicitly said it's so strange for
a man who's done a brilliant job running
a giant bank his answers around bitcoin
are sophomoric and it keeps doubling
down on them i pray i stay open-minded
my whole life
i think there's a really important point
which is frankly the economic incentive
is for jamie dimon not to like bitcoin
bitcoin is really dangerous to jp morgan
bitcoin stands for everything that jp
morgan doesn't
jb morgan is a rent seeker it's a
middleman the entire business model is
based on you not being able to do
anything for yourself it's based on you
giving them your assets and them saying
we know best trust us we'll do it for
you
instead bitcoin provides sovereignty it
allows you and i to hold our own assets
and to interact with various financial
services in a decentralized
permissionless way
no longer do we need traditional banks
and so now we have two different forces
facing each other we have people like
jamie dimon who literally think it's
worthless who literally don't believe in
software who claim that the software is
not actually
accurate or works
and then we have a whole nother system
where over a hundred million people
around the world have chosen to store
value in a decentralized digital open
monetary network
closed networks always lose to open
networks and bitcoin has absolutely
exploded in popularity but my favorite
point
is that bitcoin's a trillion dollar
asset
and the ceo of jp morgan says that it's
worthless
but you know what's funny
jamie
bitcoin's worth two times as much as
your bank
quite literally
rather than spending so much time
trying to have comments about bitcoin
your bank's only worth 500 billion
dollars
bitcoin's worth a trillion
the market the free market those who
assign value the referees of debates
has decided that bitcoin is more
valuable than jp morgan chase
so quite literally
maybe bitcoiners are going to eventually
think that jp morgan
is worthless
because that's where we're headed
is that we literally have the heads the
executives the leaders of the legacy
financial system
who are saying things like a trillion
dollar asset is worthless
what
what is going on right now and then we
have to make matters even worse the
mainstream press doesn't push back
nobody says hey dude
it's a trillion dollar asset what do you
mean it's worthless every single one of
your competitors the leaders of those
organizations don't think it's worthless
how is it possible that the leaders at
fidelity at every single other major
institution are participating in the
market in some way and are saying things
like we believe this has store value
capabilities we believe that this is
going to continue to rise in popularity
we believe that the hundred plus million
people who already hold the asset
are likely on the right side of history
how is it that nobody's questioning the
fact that jamie dimon is saying that a
trillion dollar asset is worthless it's
crazy to me what do you guys think about
this
jimmy diamond's wrong i mean like the he
he talked in one of his uh comments
about how the market decides right and
that's the beautiful thing about markets
the market has decided it has decided
that bitcoin as a network is worth two
times the amount of his business right
so when you think about it uh the market
has decided but i think ultimately the
other comment that surprised me a lot
was his relation to china like where did
that come from dude the uh china relies
talking about censorship they rely on
censorship within the news the media all
the stuff to control their citizens to
limit the ability to for their citizens
to have uh freedom of speech and other
freedoms and expressions and stuff like
that so the idea that he's going to
claim that china banned bitcoin and
that's a reason that we should look at
it and ban it also is ridiculous in my
opinion not only is he wrong when it
comes to the market deciding how much
bitcoin is worth it's obviously decided
it's worth a trillion dollars as an
asset class but outside of that china
like what dude it is not a right to be
looking at china as an example of what
we should be doing here in the united
states that is
incorrect and completely wrong in my
opinion i think uh what jamie dimon has
done is he has shown that he is not
willing to change his mind right what
mike novogat said is he he said i i hope
until the end of my life i keep an open
mind which i think is correct because
jamie dimon has sat on the sideline i
think his first comment was in 2014. i
looked it up briefly and he's missed 20
000 price appreciation on bitcoin it
would have been the best performing
asset in his portfolio by a long margin
and he has been confronted with it as a
leader in the financial industry for a
long period of time every single year he
gets asked about this multiple times a
year what do you think about bitcoin
what do you think about bitcoin what do
you think about bitcoin and he has not
changed his mind yet i think it speaks
volumes to his inability to keep an open
mind his inability to change his opinion
he has dug his feet so far in the ground
now that i don't think he probably will
ever change his opinion i hope i'm wrong
on that uh but just in general the idea
that bitcoin is worthless uh he's wrong
and i think his clients have told him
that i think a lot of other banks on
wall street have shown him that and i
think ultimately the market and the
retail traders that are uh have profited
off of this while he sat on the sideline
have proven him to be incorrect john
what do you think yeah joe hit a lot of
great points
wow a lot of what i was going to talk
about uh mike novogratz great stay
open-minded that's what the best and the
smartest people do is they are
consistently open-minded consistently
learning the 21 million uh not knowing
if they're 21 million or not or does it
stop at 21 million it's a comical
comment go read
2018 he said i don't give a [ __ ] talking
about bitcoin bro it doesn't matter i
don't care what you care about the
market will end up deciding who is right
and that's the best thing about free
markets it doesn't really matter he's
consistently trash on bitcoin and it
sounds like he gives a [ __ ] oh he
definitely sounds like he gives it oh
it's fool's goal it's like dude stop
talking about if you don't care let it
go well people to in his defense so
i want to ask
i want to defend jamie dimon for two
seconds right one is
most of the times he's talking about it
he's not offering up his opinion he's
not showing up to a conference saying
hey i want to do a talk on bitcoin right
and tell you how it sucks no people are
asking him the question so for sure uh
he's put in a position and i'm sure he
doesn't like talking about he's he's
tired of talking he knows when he says
things he's trying to say whatever his
talking points are and then he just
absolutely you know his head bashed in
online in terms of all the people just
yelling and screaming and saying how
he's wrong etc so i'm sure he doesn't
want to do that stuff the second thing
that i'll say in defense of him is that
he has doubled and tripled down to joe's
point so much
that it would be miraculous at this
point for him to change his mind and
he's probably gotten a positive feedback
loop
from
all of the clients of the bank
right a bunch of those people probably
said to him yeah we really liked what
you had to say about uh bitcoin we like
the fact that you're uh you think it's
risky we like the fact that you think
that actually uh it could go to zero and
so somewhere
somebody is telling him that these
talking points are the right things
right it's very very low probability
that he says this stuff he goes back to
his office and literally the people that
his colleagues the younger people at the
firm the customers etc are all saying to
him hey i think you're wrong on bitcoin
and he keeps saying no no i'm gonna keep
doing it right the odds that he's
literally flying in the face of every
person he talks to and continuing to say
this is very low the second thing is as
he's presented with more information
he's not changing his mind
right it's one thing when it's a
20 billion dollar asset another thing
when it's 100 billion dollar asset then
it's a trillion dollar asset it's
another thing when all of a sudden you
have fidelity and other major banks all
participating it's another thing when
all of a sudden you see multiple
companies in the industry starting to go
public et cetera
data point after data point after data
point after data point and he's not
changing his mind
i actually think that people give folks
like this a harder time than they
usually deserve because it's a really
complex job you're the ceo of a major
bank you've got nine million things
going on you can't be an expert in
everything and so a lot of times what
ends up happening is they're just
parroting and repeating the talking
points that somebody internally gave
them but i don't think that's what is
happening in this specific case i
actually believe that he thinks what he
believes what he's saying
and the issue is that either one nobody
sat him down and explained it to him or
two he's literally just missing
something because i've never seen anyone
who's taken the time to learn about it
who then walks away and says you know
what
i actually don't think it has any value
they may say it's overvalued they may
say i don't think it's going to realize
the full promise of what people in the
community think they may have caveats to
it but nobody walks away saying it's
worthless
again a trillion dollar asset that's
held by 100 million people around the
world
a nation state just made it
legal tender
there's multiple
large institutional investors in the
united states and abroad that hold the
asset on their balance sheets
how could it be worthless you know what
uh well first off jamie dimon's bank
received a 25 billion dollar bailout
from taxpayers in 2008 so that's just
one fact you're gonna drop bombs like
that there we go uh second off i think
the best thing yesterday and i think
frankly what what jamie dimon might be a
little mad about is bitcoin didn't care
bitcoin didn't care at all it was up
five six percent on the day it's closing
on an all-time high right like it
doesn't care it's continuing to operate
as designed more people are adopting the
protocol every single day like you said
it's become legal tender in a country
it's it's inevitable at this point i
think jamie dimon uh is proving to other
people
he's obviously super super super
intelligent i don't think a lot of the
some guy in the comments said he's going
to be working for pomp boys motors by
2025.
guys i think jamie dive is going to be
over here he's got 2 billion dollars i
don't know we'd love to have him i guess
but but uh no he's not the oil changes
yeah he could do the oil change or
something but i don't think he's gonna
be working for palm boys motors so that
stuff's funny but i just think it's
interesting that like bitcoin didn't
care at all right like this is the type
of information that used to matter a lot
and used to move markets right like an
elon tweet jamie dimon saying it's
worthless all this stuff two three four
years ago used to move markets a lot 10
we'd see drawdowns and stuff like that
and yesterday just didn't matter at all
which i thought was super interesting